die neue scienceh dr Watson live aus der
Zukunft wie werden wir uns in der
Zukunft fortbewegen ernähren Energie
erzeugen wie wird künstliche Intelligenz
alles verändern und werden Menschen auf
dem Mars Leben all das und noch viel
mehr zeige ich euch auf einer Bühne in
eurer Nähe holt euch jetzt Tickets unter
drwatson.shop
201 im dritten Jahr ihrer Doktorarbeit
weigert sich zoesiani die Arbeit von
gleich drei der bekanntesten
Forscherinnen und Forscher ihres Gebiets
zu berücksichtigen irgendetwas stimmt
mit den Ergebnissen nicht das ist ihr
sofort klar aber ihre Chefin besteht
darauf sie soll die bahnbrechende Studie
zitieren die sogar hier bei uns in die
Headlines geschafft hat siani beugt sich
dem Druck auf ihre Art und beschließt
die Studie in ihrer Doktorarbeit
ausgiebig zu kritisieren und dann kommt
es wie es kommen musste der Plan geht
nach hinten los eine Gutachterin nennt
die Kritik unangemessen selbstgerecht
und hetzerisch und auch die anderen
Gutachter sind erbost ihr wird gedroht
die Promotion platzen zu lassen um ihre
Karriere zu retten entfernt siani die
Kritik aus der Arbeit erstmal 5 Jahre
später 2023 wird sie einen der größten
wissenschaftsskandale der letzten Jahre
aufgedeckt haben heute erzählen wir euch
die Geschichte wie eine frisch gebackene
Forscherin und drei datendetektive einer
hochkarätigen datenfälscherin das
Handwerk gelegt
haben in dem fraglichen Fachartikel ging
es um karrierenetworking trotz der
Vorteile die es bietet finden Menschen
die Kontaktaufnahme allein für den
persönlichen Nutzen oft unangenehm die
Studie wollte zeigen dass sich Menschen
nach einem Networking Event moralisch
unrein und sogar physisch schmutzig
fühlen die Evidenz wenn man den
Teilnehmern nach dem Event unter
Versuchsbedingungen eine Liste von
Produkten zu lesen gab bewerteten sie
persönliche Reinigungsprodukte als
begehrenswerter über diese Studie
berichtete damals übrigens auch unter
anderem der Spiegel und der Bericht ist
immer noch online aber der Mechanismus
nachdem Menschen mit Schuldgefühlen
diese im wörtlichen Sinne von sich
abwaschen wollen der war bereits 2014
widerlegt worden diese Studie hätte also
überhaupt nicht funktionieren sollen hat
sie aber wie konnte das sein zunächst
vermutete zoesiani nur dass sich die
Forscherinnen und Forscher einige
Freiheiten bei der Auswertung genommen
hatten ein bekanntes Problem bei vielen
Forschungsergebnissen aus dieser Zeit
dabei werden statistiktricks eingesetzt
um negative Ergebnisse in positive zu
verwandeln wie funktioniert das genau
bei der statistischen Auswertung von
versuchen will man meistens herausfinden
ob das Ergebnis des Versuchs sich von
dem Ergebnis eines kontrollversuchs
wirklich unterscheidet in einer
Medikamentenstudie vergleicht man z.B
die Wirkung eines Medikaments mit der
Wirkung eines plazbos wenn man die
Ergebnisse der einzelnen Testpersonen
grafisch darstellt ergibt sich eine Art
Wolke aus Daten weil jede Person ein
bisschen anders auf die Behandlung
reagiert der statistische Test soll
jetzt ermitteln wie wahrscheinlich es
ist dass die Unterschiede zwischen den
beiden Datenwolken einfach nur Zufall
sind das sagt uns der Ergebniswert P P
kann einen Wert zwischen 0 und 1 haben
und wenn der Wert 0,05 oder kleiner ist
dann gilt der Unterschied zwischen den
Ergebnissen also der Effekt als
statistisch signifikant das bedeutet
dass mit mindestens 95%zentiger
Wahrscheinlichkeit der Unterschied
zwischen den beiden Gruppen kein Zufall
ist und man sich recht sicher sein kann
dass der Effekt echt ist ein p-Wert von
0,051 wäre also schon zu viel und
natürlich gilt je niedriger desto besser
ein Problem dieser Konvention ist dass
Fachartikel die keine statistisch
signifikanten Ergebnisse vorweisen
können von Fachjournalen eher abgelehnt
werden und da Veröffentlichungen wichtig
für die Karriere sind entsteht dadurch
ein Anreiz für Forscherinnen und
Forscher die Ergebnisse zu schönen und
das geht mit P hacking dabei testet man
z.B während des laufenden Versuchs immer
wieder die Statistik und beendet ihn
genau dann wenn der p-Wert gerade
zufällig gut aussieht oder man wählt
beim Aussortieren schlechter Messwerte
die Ausschlusskriterien so dass die
gewünschten Ergebnisse herauskommen oder
man probiert einfach verschiedene
statistische Testverfahren durch bis man
ein signifikantes Ergebnis erhält und
die anderen na ja die lässt man halt
verschwinden P haacking schließt dr
siani bei der Verdächtigen Studie aber
aus dafür sind die Ergebnisse zu
eindeutig der p-Wert ist zu niedrig und
der angebliche Effekt zu groß deswegen
wiederholt sie sogar eines der
Experimente aus dem paper und bekommt
völlig andere Ergebnisse das heißt es
ist noch schlimmer als gedacht hier
wurden nicht nur Zahlen geschönt sondern
schwerere Geschütze aufgefahren
gemeinsam mit einer anonymen Forscherin
prüft sie dann die veröffentlichten
Daten mehrerer Forschungsartikel der
beteiligten Autoren und darin stoßen sie
immer wieder auf verdächtig eindeutige
Ergebnisse und ungereimt en in den
datenetzen der Verdacht erhärtet sich
hier liegt Datenfälschung vor und alle
Spuren laufen auf eine bestimmte Autorin
zu die verhaltensforscherin und Harvard
Professorin dr Francesca Gino Francesca
gino ist ein Shootingstar der
Wissenschaft vom Bachelor in Italien zur
Harvard vollprofessur in nur 9 Jahren
alle von siani ausgemachten Verdächtigen
Artikel hat Gino in ihrer Zeit als
Professorin veröffentlicht und sich
damit einen großen Namen gemacht und
ausgerechnet dietik wurden tausendfach
zitiert in denen es um unethisches
Verhalten und Unehrlichkeit ging h und
Ginos Reputation als bahnbrechende
Forscherin zahlt sich aus sie verdient
über eine Million US-Dollar pro Jahr
dazu kommen Einkünfte als Autorin als
Rednerin und als Wirtschaftsberaterin
Francesca gino ist eine der mächtigsten
Personen auf dem Gebiet der
Verhaltensökonomie siani und ihre
Helferin brauchen also Unterstützung
deshalb wenden sie sich 2021 an die
datendetektive von data
[Musik]
datacada ist ein Blog von drei
Professoren aus der Verhaltensforschung
er behandelt Themen rund um Daten und
Statistik und eben auch Datenfälschung
die Autoren von datacolladaer wollen die
Harvard Universität überzeugen
Untersuchungen durchzuführen für die ist
ein Skandal und das Zurückziehen von
Fachartikeln ja aber mega rufschädigend
wenn die Uni einen Grund findet
Anschuldigungen einfach abzulehnen dann
wird sie das auch tun
laut zoesiani waren die Autoren von
datacollada deshalb super kritisch und
suchten nach plausiblen Erklärungen
selbst für die offensichtlichsten
Ungereimtheiten für siani eine im
positiven Sinne frustrierende Erfahrung
zur tiefsten Enttäuschung unseres
Redakteurs können wir jetzt leider nicht
auf jedes Detail der datenforensik hier
eingehen sorry Dennis aber wenn euch
datenforensik auch fasziniert dann
schaut ihr gerne mal in die Quellen wir
haben euch wie immer alles verlinkt und
es ist wirklich super spannend in Kürze
die datendetektive fanden in den
veröffentlichten Datensätzen Einträge
die auf unterschiedliche Weise
herausstechen z.B war ein Datensatz nach
der teilnehmenden ID sortiert aber
einige IDs waren außer der Reihe und es
gab Dopplungen in einem anderen Beispiel
sollen eine Reihe von
versuchsteilnehmenden die Frage wie
lange sie schon studieren angeblich mit
Harvard beantwortet haben man sollte ja
denken dass man in Harvard den
Unterschied zwischen wo und wie lange
kennt in einer grafischen Darstellung
fiel auf dass genau diese auffälligen
Einträge die Datenwolke in eine
bestimmte Richtung verschoben dadurch
wurde das statistisch nicht signifikante
Ergebnis auf einmal statistisch
signifikant so oder so ähnliche Muster
fanden sich dann in allen vier
Datensätzen im Herbst 2021 wanden sich
siani und dataakada dann mit ihren
Befunden an die Harvard Business School
die schaltet eigene berufsmäßige Daten
forensicaa ein es folgte eine 18
monatige interne Untersuchung die erst
2023 abgeschlossen wurde der 1200
seitige Bericht wurde wegen eines
Gerichtsverfahrens in Auszügen
veröffentlicht mit Zugriff auf die
Originaldaten hatten die Forensiker noch
viele weitere gefälschte Einträge
ausgemacht teilweise waren über die
Hälfte der Daten eines Experiments
gefälscht alle von datacollada
bemängelten Fachartikel wurden
inzwischen auf Anfrage der Harvard
Business School von den jeweiligen
Fachjournalen zurückgezogen aber im
Spiegel sind die gefälschen Ergebnisse
immer noch online über die Jahre hatte
Gino zusammen mit insgesamt 143
Forscherinnen und Forschern 139
Fachartikel veröffentlicht der Ruf all
dieser Menschen steht nun auch auf dem
Spiel deshalb riefen einige von ihnen
dazu auf gemeinsam all diese Fachartikel
zu überprüfen dazu gehört auch Uri
simonson von dataacada selbst Francesca
Gino seit letzten Sommer von ihrem
Posten entfernt und beurlaubt beteuert
übrigens noch immer ihre Unschuld
schiebt die Manipulation auf technische
Assistenten oder bezeichnet die
Originaldaten als unfertige vorläufige
Datensätze aus der Zeit als sie erstellt
wurden deshalb verklagt sie dataacada
Harvard und den Dekan der Harvard
Business School derzeit auf 25 Millionen
USDollar Schadensersatz das Verfahren
läuft wenn man so hört mit welchen
Summen sich die Leute da teilweise
gegenseitig verklagen kann man nur
hoffen dass sie gut versichert sind
vielleicht ja auch mit clar wusstet ihr
z.B dass nur 23% der Deutschen glauben
dass sie im Alter ihren Lebensstandard
halten können mit KAG könnt ihr eure
aktuelle Rentensituation schnell
überblicken außerdem bekommt ihr Tipps
wie ihr eure Altersvorsorge verbessern
könnt bei Bedarf auch in einer
persönlichen Beratung ihr solltet aber
wissen dass clar als Makler für euch
Auftritt das ist hilfreich wenn die
Versicherungen einfach kündigen oder
neue abschließen wollt wird aber auch
relevant wenn ihr schon einen Makler
habt der verliert dadurch nämlich sein
Mandat an clar außerdem optimiert clar
euren Schutz teilweise auch automatisch
wenn es bestehende Versicherungen
günstiger oder zum gleichen Preis in
besser gibt voraorausgesetzt natürlich
ihr widersprecht den Änderungen nicht
innerhalb von 14 Tagen wenn ihr clar
also ausprobieren wollt dann klickt
einfach auf den den ersten Link unten in
der Videobeschreibung oder gibt bei der
Registrierung den Code Watson 14 ein
damit bekommt ihr nämlich für bis zu
drei bestehende Versicherungen jeweils
einen 15 € Gutschein für Cyberport
Amazon oder den App Store und ihr
unterstützt natürlich auch noch uns und
unsere Videos vielen Dank
dafür okay alles in allem wurden
schwerwiegende Vorwürfe gegen Francesca
Gino erhoben und sie versucht sich mit
einer Klage auf Schadensersatz zu wehren
aber wir glauben nicht dass man bei
Harvard eine ihrer bekanntesten
Führungspersönlichkeiten des Betrugs
bezichtigt wenn man sich bei der Sache
nicht 100ertprozentig sicher wäre
schließlich schadet so ein Fall auch der
eigenen Reputation wir erwarten deshalb
nicht dass Gino damit durchkommt die
Geschichte von zoesiani zeigt dass
gefälschte Fachartikel großen Schaden an
Forschung und Forschungskarriere
anrichten können in der Zeit in der
geninus Artikel als Grundpfeiler ihres
Forschungsbereichs galten haben bestimmt
viele forschende ihre Zeit und
Ressourcen mit dem Versuch wendet darauf
aufzubauen und gerade für Promovierende
ist es schwierig und potenziell
karriereschädigend die Arbeit von
forschungspromis zu bemäeln die
Geschichte von Francesca Gino zeigt auf
der anderen Seite wie weit man mit
datenfelschon kommen kann deshalb sind
unverlässliche Ergebnisse in
Fachartikeln nicht so selten wie man
hoffen mag gino ist nur einer von
mehreren Fällen der jüngeren Zeit so
kann auch der bekannte Sozialpsychologe
dan arelli Manipulationen an Daten auf
die nur er Zugriff hatte nicht leen aber
auch der Ex-Präsident von Stanford Mark
Tessier Lavin ist wegen Datenfälschung
in seinen Laboren zurückgetreten
Datenfälschung ist auch nicht das
einzige Problem phacking haben wir
gerade schon erwähnt auch Plagiate
kommen vor und inzwischen versuchen
einige sogar KI generierten Blödsinn als
wissenschaftliche Artikel zu
veröffentlichen die meisten
unzuverlässigen Studien enthalten aber
wohl einfach ehrliche Irrtümer laut
nature wurden 2023 weltweit über 10000
Artikel zurück zogen etwa 0,2% aller
Veröffentlichungen Tendenz steigend und
experten vermuten dass das nur die
Spitze des icebergs ist was wird dagegen
getan auf die replikationskrise in der
Psychologie wurde mit einem Projekt
reagiert das hunderte Studien
wiederholte einige Journals verlangen
eine eingehende Prüfung der Statistik
dafür gibt es sogar schon automatisierte
Systeme die Verdächtige Statistiken im
Text eines fachartikels herauslesen und
Flagen können bei manchen kann man eine
Studie anmelden bevor man sie durchführt
wird das Studiendesign akzeptiert wird
die Studie später auf jeden Fall in den
Journal veröffentlicht egal wie das
Ergebnis ausfällt das nimmt den Druck
einen bestimmten p-Wert zu erreichen und
es wird immer üblicher nicht nur den
Fachartikel sondern auch die
dazugehörigen Daten zu veröffentlichen
so können Leserinnen und Leser die
Auswertung nachvollziehen vielleicht ist
es einfach wegen eines Prominenten
Falles wie diesem das Vertrauen in die
Wissenschaft zu verlieren aber ich finde
am Ende zeigen doch gerade die diese
Fälle dass die Wissenschaft sehr wohl
die Fähigkeit hat sich selbst zu
korrigieren auch wenn man sich
vielleicht wünschen würde dass die
Hürden für Whistleblower niedriger und
die Zeiträume kürzer wären in diesem
Sinne bleibt kritisch aber bleibt wie
immer neugierig euer Cedrick